here's a quick question and by now you
know the rules please don't google it or
Wikipedia or whatever and the question
is what do you know about Armenia what
do you really know about this remote
country located in the Caucasus region
now watch out because Armenia has some
very interesting traits for example it
was the first Christian country in all
of history it's a chess world power and
it even has its own alphabet
[Music]
and here's another fact that you might
not know about this country inside of
the country is not really sure how to
say this but essentially there's another
country in there this country is the
self constituted republic of art sack
formerly known as an Agora acara back
you heard that right we're talking about
a republic that isn't recognized by any
other country in the world but which
proclaimed its independence in 1991 and
has its own government Parliament's
Constitution and even its own Armed
Forces
[Music]
you see except for a passport with which
they can travel the world they have
everything
of course this curious Republic citizens
aren't all isolated they all have an
Armenian passport because this country
is a close ally of Armenia you see
during the Soviet period this territory
was an Oblast an autonomous province of
the as mazzani Soviet Socialist Republic
but when the Soviet Union collapsed its
government decided that it wanted to
belong to Armenia which led to a long
four-year war that caused thousands of
deaths by the way interesting slide
there here have you ever noticed in
history how many wars have happened
simply over a tiny piece of land let's
stay on topic for today maybe that's
something we'll talk about in the future
now most would agree that Armenia has
absolutely everything required to dazzle
a politics addicts and of course
everything required for us to talk about
it right here on visual politic one
country inside another one a recent war
in 2016 a huge diaspora a democratic
revolution and even the potential to be
a headache for mr. Vladimir Putin
himself so listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
with no sea access a location surrounded
by huge mountains and less than three
million inhabitants
I believe dear viewer that we can call
Armenia a pretty remote place if we had
to briefly describe this country we
would say that it's not far off from the
typical Hollywood portrayal of the
former Soviet republic of course though
unlike Hollywood they don't have a rebel
military and they certainly don't have a
desire to return to communism but the
truth is that this country has many many
problems see Armenia gained its
independence in September of 1991 and
today 27 years later unemployment
surpasses 20 percent one in every three
citizens lives in poverty public debt
has multiplied by four in the last
decade alone infrastructure is falling
apart and on top of all of that they
have a serious immigration problem yes
you heard that right immigration you see
it's estimated that there are about 12
million Armenians around the world but
only 3 million of them actually live in
Armenia therefore we're talking about
one of the largest diasporas in the
entire world and only one out of every
five Armenians lives in Armenia itself
and if that wasn't astonishing enough
every year on average 40,000 Armenians
leave the country and in many cases they
simply never return worst of all things
do not seem to be improving check out
for example the evolution of foreign
investments in recent years
but at this point you might be wondering
well why are things going quite so badly
well Divya one of the reasons is
certainly corruption and the huge amount
of power that oligarchs in the country
possess you see in the last 20 years the
Republican Armenian Party hate
theoretically center-right and pro
market party that's really just a huge
Club of oligarchs has turns the
country's politics into a network of
interests and privileges let's put it
another way for two entire decades if
you wanted to do business in Armenia
joining this party was almost a
mandatory step and if you were a
foreigner dropping by wasn't a bad idea
either
however just hold on a moment here
because in April of 2018
Armenians said well enough is enough and
you know what they did well they held a
revolution in the streets check this out
the Revolution
after ten disastrous years empowered
after exhausting his maximum number of
mandates President Serzh Sargsyan tried
to copy Putin's strategy and get elected
as Prime Minister
[Music]
to do this he proposed a reform that
basically passed the president's main
powers on to the prime minister so what
do you think happens at this point are
we talking about a smart maneuver to
stay in power or a blatant mockery to
all Armenians
well dear viewer it was very very clear
to the people of this country the
presidents he was laughing at them
he could rig the elections use his power
at will and let big oligarchs use the
government to get rich but this this was
too much after 10 years of presidents
ergs terrible management's this was
beyond a joke the Armenians they did not
accept it
[Applause]
on April the 13th nickel passion yarn a
journalists and opposition deputy in the
Armenian Parliament's led a protest
mobilization at the beginning very few
people joined this protest but in a
matter of days things changed a great
deal on April the 16th large groups of
students joined the protest and four
days later on Friday April 4 20th the
movement had already concentrated in
Yerevan the country's capital with tens
of thousands of people appearing at that
moment the government's which up until
then had seen the demonstrations as a
small nuisance began to get rather
nervous and what do you think they did
at this point well they did what tyrants
do they arrested the main leaders of
these completely peaceful demonstrations
including their leader Nikolas passion
young they also announced that the
police would disperse the protest
rallies by force and without any
considerations
[Music]
so at this point you might think that
well that was the end of the movement
right well in fact no just the opposite
happened it was the point of no return
from that moment more than two hundred
thousand people in a country a fewer
than 3 million inhabitants took to the
Capitol streets the country it was
paralyzed work centers schools and
universities they all closed
[Applause]
[Music]
and the police faced with such a massive
concentration of people well they
decided to do absolutely nothing so all
of this encouraged more and more people
to join in a completely peaceful and
really quite happy protest finally
Armenia's citizens have stood up and
said enough sin nuff The Velvet
Revolution is under way
and what was the result well at 4:00
p.m. on Monday April the 23rd just 10
days after the protests began the
president announced his resignation a
few weeks later Puccini and himself the
protest leader a journalist - in recent
years had suffered an attempted attack
and had been imprisoned for confronting
the government had now been appointed
prime minister yes it was a pretty crazy
few weeks from opponent to prisoner and
from prisoner to the government's all in
just a few days
[Music]
and the thing is when a society stabs up
to demand freedom democracy and justice
it's kind of hard to stop them
Armenia now has a chance to change its
course and to face the oligarchs and
ends the widespread corruption that's
been consuming the country we have a new
Armenia now where each investment will
be protected and no investment will be
threatened any longer Nicolle passion
Yin Kara for group is one of the largest
companies in the sugar trade but this
company is forbidden to import sugar to
Armenia we need to allow them to do this
as well as allow other companies and we
will definitely do it there should be no
monopolies in Armenia
Nicole passion ian armenian prime
minister of course all going for just a
moment because it's certainly not going
to be easy for one because the
republican party still controls Congress
and its representatives have already
stated that they won't resign or make it
easy for the new prime minister and
that's not all as if that wasn't enough
apart from their own internal problems
Armenia has two other important
challenges and one of them is Vladimir
Putin's Russia
rush and the Azzurri threats Moscow has
such a huge amount of control over
armenia's economy defense and foreign
policy that many analysts speak openly
about a kind of de-facto occupation
without going any further in the
Armenian city of gilmurry the Russian
army has right next to the Turkish
border an important military base with
more than 5,000 soldiers mig-29
aircrafts and s-300 anti-aircraft
missile systems but it isn't just a
military issue to a large extent the
country also depends on the remittances
sent by more than two million Armenians
who are currently living in Russia and
in addition the Russian giant is its
main commercial partner and completely
controls their energy supply I mean
check this out what is curtain Armenia
is something unnatural it is next to
Iran a major exporter of gas but it
imports its gas from Siberia as a result
of agreements that do little more than
legalize Armenians occupation indeed
under the terms of those Accords Yerevan
can't make a deal with Tehran unless
Moscow agrees Rubin McGraw bein the
editor of the Russian service of the one
in am internet portal the fact is that
so far Vladimir Putin has had very good
relations with the government and do you
all know that these kind of revolutions
they don't exactly thrill person so
there's a warning on the table here do
not pay too much attention to the
seductive calls of the European Union or
the United States certainly the 5,000
Russian soldiers stationed in Armenia
certainly helped put this message from
Moscow across but that is not all there
is also another huge threat here
remember the Republic of Arts act that I
mentioned her right at the beginning of
the video well it's sort of a
protectorate of Armenia in such a way
that Azerbaijan considers it to be an
occupied territory
indeed they've had no qualms about
expressing their intention to reap
conquer it and here it must be said that
confrontations aren't unusual hands are
even relatively recent in 2016 hard
confrontations took place there for four
days until Vladimir Putin demanded a
ceasefire but obviously the risk exists
especially because Azerbaijan has oil
and gas and that dear viewer that means
money to give you an idea as a Bajans
military budget is as big as the
Armenian government's entire budget so
if one day Russia decides to wash its
hands Armenia could certainly get into a
lot of trouble anyway that is how things
stand in the country today but now is
your turn have you even heard of the
republic of art sack well leave your
answer in the comment section below as
well as in this survey and i really hope
you enjoyed this video please do hit
that like button if you did and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos also don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
Media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that are not mine and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]
[Applause]